Anytime I've had to do a transcript for,
cause I don't write anything down Longhand,
but when I've had to do a transcript for tonight's show or like just for laughs
festival and see it,
then you start writing new tags and you're like,
all this took was for me to write it out.
But then what do you do from Microsoft word?
Then you take it to get to that scrivener and then what do you do there?
Put it,
I take the stuff from Microsoft word and then I trim it down and when I trim it
down,
I put it in scrivener and when I've trim it down and put it in Scribnar,
what I'm essentially doing is saying,
okay,
this is ready,
this is ready to play.
And then what it scrivener do?
Oh Shit,
I left my fucking notebook in a hotel room.
God dammit damn,
someone's going to freak out.
So then from there I write things out on an actual notebook and the actual
notebook is basically just to get my set list in order and to make sure I
highlight all the different tags.
So there's three stages.
There's the Microsoft word stage,
which is basically just free form free association,
writing things down.
No,
there's no structure to it.
Sometimes it comes out like a bit,
sometimes it's just nonsense that never goes anywhere.
Okay.
You needed to get out anyway so you could get to other stuff
you just urging.
Yeah,
well it's,
I don't know if you need it,
but it's like there's a road they get onto and as you're on that road,
all of a sudden you're like,
oh look,
I found a bag of gold and,
and you don't find that bag of gold.
If you stay home,
you gotta walk,
you gotta get out there.
And that's,
that's what the writing does with the writing does,
it allows you to pick up these little bags of gold along the way.
And then I take these little bags of gold when I pile them up and then I throw
them into the fortress and the fortress is like scrivener.
So then I can move those bits around.
What is scrivener did?
Like,
what is it?
Why was it different than Microsoft?
Well,
the reason why
it's different,
it's because it's set up in columns,
right?
So you see how,
and it's also has cork boards.
See Jamie's got it up on the big screen.
So when the cork boards see how it's set up right here,
like each one of these things,
if you go to the the left side here,
each one of these categories I can move and I can,
I can change,
I can have that bit in the beginning at the end.
And then once I'm in the bit I could also go to this and that sets me up with a
cork board.
So I can have like,
I could set up little,
uh,
nope.
Like little a set setlist well like that,
like up there little notepad things.
So I could write down these on these index cards.
Like don't forget this or this is important here.
Or this tagline is huge.
Try switching this around and it's just this constant.
But are you already like this or you already this kind of an organized person.
Have you always been this way or did you get those?
You have to know this is a discipline.